look we did hear this story that you
once met rihanna at a party
and kind of tried to dance with her give
me your best pitch for rihanna playing
one of anthony's love interests
i mean i'm i'm really up for it if she
is
um i mean the chemistry
will say i feel bad i feel bad even
telling that story but you know
it was one of my proudest moments
hopefully we can at least get her on the
soundtrack
i am so excited to talk to you but how
long have you known about season two
we're just finding out
did you know it was gonna happen well i
think you can tell from the length of my
beard when i started to grow up those
modern jobs so that was about three days
what is it like to have those sideburns
do you was it weird to have them in your
normal life while you were filming
to say it didn't slightly affect my um
my social uh
endeavors it would be it would be
fibbing but yeah no
i i've missed them so i'm i'm like i've
missed the whole casting
and career well you guys are gonna get
back into production this spring we're
so excited
what can you tell me about this season
what can you tease about the vi counts
journey to love
i think it's gonna be quite a
complicated um affair as we know of
anthony um
i think there's a lot that he needs to
learn um and a lot he can learn from
daphne i'm sure and simon um but you
know the world
is being so celebrated and all the
amazing characters
in the bridge and family the french and
family and all their friends there's
going to be so much for all of them to
experience and
um yeah i think we're just like really
excited to continue that story
and now with millions of fans as well to
speak strictly there's nothing wrong
with him
what should i need for you to marry him
nigel i had to find your husband's
sister now
be grateful it is done the response is
amazing
will we see any of his old love
interests come back
i can tease only so much
i get nervous i get nervous at these
questions you don't want to upset shonda
rhimes she loves a secret
she doesn't and we're all we're we're
all in on on
yeah we'll have to wait and see it's
going to be brilliant i think well
we know he's going to meet many love
interests we hope he'll have his own
season
do you have anybody who you know who's
playing these love interests or any
dream castings
i mean once you've had julie andrews
involved in the world is your oyster
isn't it
there's so many ways in which you know i
mean we could get i mean share
let's get sharing okay that's the real
dream
look we did hear this story that you
once met rihanna at a party
and kind of tried to dance with her give
me your best pitch for rihanna playing
one of anthony's love interests
i mean i'm i'm really up for if she is
um i mean the chemistry was there
i will say i feel bad i feel bad even
telling that story but you know
it was one of my proudest moments
hopefully we can at least get around the
soundtrack
um reggae's career it just blew up he's
got millions of followers on instagram
are you
prepared for things to blow up for you
now that you are the main
character well you know what i'm really
happy at the moment receiving messages
uh on instagram with people saying that
please really i do really want reggae to
respond so could you just put in a word
so i feel like i'm his assistant i'm
really happy with that you've been his
wingman thus far
of course yeah i mean he's brilliant i
mean and so is phoebe i mean
yeah it's just an exciting moment i
think for everyone will we
see them back i don't know if it would
feel like the show without all of the
bridge or tim's
well of course i mean it's a family and
as we know once you're wedded into the
bridges family i think you're there for
life
where are you has reggae uh and phoebe
have they given you any advice on how to
prepare for the explosion you're
probably about to face
well but you know we're all so close
we're all sort of a family anyway um so
i know i've got a support but yeah i
think uh they've they've led the charge
with such grace and elegance that um
yeah i know i'll be well and truly i'll
always have someone at the end of the
phone
which i think is it's good it's probably
really amazing
well there's even been a bridgerton the
musical
brewing on tick-tock which is
amazing yes it's amazing yeah and
there's i thought yes
we're all just so sort of in awe because
it's all happened over
48 hours and the amazing moment of
stillness in the world and that sort of
creativity but yeah i'm down and the
vocals on it well
my question is what will the very sexy
scenes that we've grown to love
be like now that we're filming in the
pandemic will you guys have to make any
adjustments
i think there's an incredible the best
thing about our industry is that we can
adapt
and um there will have to be ways i
think the thing that is so at the heart
of brigitte is
is intimacy um and identity and
sexuality
um and so of course that's something
that we're gonna have to make sure we
continue
with and and the amazing uh producers
will
work magic i'm sure to make sure that we
still get the stevens that
we all deserve i mean those scenes are
close they're very close and personal
you guys have an intimacy coach right
what does that person actually do before
and after the scenes it's
amazing and i cannot believe that the
industry you know there was a time where
they weren't included in the process but
they basically come in you have a
one-on-one
you talk about your personal experiences
and any boundaries you might have before
you then
deal with the actual scene and then you
talk it through with the actor so
basically before a director or anyone
comes in
you have an idea of exactly what you're
doing what is it like for you to film
those scenes in front of all the cast
and crew though i mean
it's got to be a feat yeah i mean it's
they they call they call they call the
moment and everyone sort of leaves and
say
you are sort of left um to your own
devices a little bit um but yeah no i
think
i think just like anything i think the
ice is thawed and then they get easier
and easier
but you do really need to get on um and
sabrina bartlett who played sienna
um you know the amazing um love interest
in
season one was so brilliant we've gotten
so well so i'm excited to
to fall in love vicariously again with
another amazing actress
i have to grill you a little bit more on
what we're gonna get
in season two my friend because in
season one we had the mystery right of
lady whistle down and what would happen
uh with with daphne and with simon what
do you think is kind of
the mystery that we're facing in season
two
well there's a big mystery with the
featherington family if you remember
that their whole estate has been left to
someone we don't know who that is i
think there's so many
cliffhangers and all the characters the
amazing characters and the siblings from
british family had
huge like character moments of discovery
there's so much
um and so i think yeah this is only the
beginning and
i i know with chris um at the hound
which is going to get more
exciting convoluted and sexier now what
about the books because this addictive
series is based on the books
will we see the same story as we see in
anthony's story in the books
i think um chris van dusen the show
runner has got this amazing ability to
take julia quinn's
extraordinary books and her amazing
worlds and she's so delicately and
you know filled full of sort of
excitement and sexiness and
he takes it to a whole other level so
the fact that we're following anthony's
pursuit for love shows that you know
there's going to be definitely some
similarities but with chris van dusen
behind it and shonda i think it's just
going to explode well
fans of the book are needing me to ask
you will we see the kate sheffield
character is that who he ends up with
i mean all i can say is
having having read the second book if
anthony gets to me
anyone as half as brilliant as kate
sheffield is the character that he's
gonna be a very lucky man
and who is gonna play kate sheffield
sorry there's a problem with the line
you